hahaha
where's the coffee mat
[Applause]
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that reminds you that all the
creepiest pastas came from the 1980s
Hulk Hogan he's got pasta Mania in the
Mall of America I want to try to get a
word with him pasta Mania he's gonna
hold my hulkamaniacs running wild and
I've eaten so many hawkeroos and hulky
use I kind of feel sorry fun fact that
restaurant would go on to receive three
Michelin stars well I hope you carbo
loaded on that pasta media hulka Maniacs
cause tonight we're no clipping once
more into the back rooms the analog
horror series right here on YouTube
produced by Kane pixels last time we
wandered through these jaundiced
hallways we were looking for a means of
escape a way to survive the endless Maze
of humming fluorescence and Soggy
carpets but today we're looking for
something different we're looking for
specifically we want answers at this
point Kane's series is three months old
and in that amount of time he's given us
10 videos full of creepy mysteries for
us to chew on what are the back room
really did Humanity create them have
they just been a parallel Dimension all
along and what about the dead man that
we find hidden in the middle of the maze
covered in a violent explosion of black
who is this guy what is this guy and
most importantly of all should we be
concerned about that monster Roman Halls
probably right usually a giant roaring
thread is something to be concerned
about so throw on your hazmat suits
friends and grab your toe lines today
we're going in deep
first let's talk about timeline shall we
part of what makes the lore of the back
room so hard to crack in an initial
watch is that it follows the tried and
true formula of series like the Walton
files Mandela catalog and FNAF where the
story is just told out of order the very
first upload of the series back rooms
found footage actually comes last in the
timeline currently September 23 1996 so
through the power of reorganization
let's recap what we know in the order
that we know it our Story begins in 1982
with async a corporation conducting
scientific research into magnetism and
or electromagnetic field generators
under government contract during the
Cold War in our first video of the
series prototype a video that no joke
released as I was writing this paragraph
So forgive me if I miss anything we get
our first event of the series a metallic
marble is surrounded by what appears to
be electromagnetic field generating
tubes notice how the shape and general
design matches diagrams for similar
real-life generators the system fires up
and just like that the ball is gone
presumably teleported to some space
within space thereby making the ball a
Subspace Emissary if you will I hate
myself for that joke but then again you
don't pass up the opportunity to make
the very rare Subspace Emissary joke
Anyway by July of 1988 async emboldened
by that initial success has given their
Distortion field experiments a
room-sized glow up called project kv-31
according to the video the third test
the goal of these experiments was to
solve quote all future storage and
housing needs so it seems like the
foundation of our story here is that
science discovers an entire other
Universe of endless space and our first
thought was hey it's a good place to
store our junk in total async conducts
five failed tests to try and open a
portal to this Subspace before the sixth
finally proves successful on October 17
1989 at 504 PM Pacific with the
generator beefed up and something
redacted being introduced into something
else redacted the threshold gets cranked
up and blasts out a light show that
seems to almost shake the facility apart
When the Smoke Clears the back rooms
themselves have finally appeared on the
other end async has achieved first
Contact unfortunately that's not the
only thing that happened that date and
time 504 pm on October 17 1989 also
happened to be in reality the moment of
magnitude 6.9 low hit the Central Coast
of California killing 63 and injuring
thousands more the timing here is
clearly not meant to be a coincidence as
a secret unlisted video on Kane pixel's
Channel gives us real archival news
footage from the Loma Prieta Quake
including a map highlighting the
location of the earthquake's epicenter
the Santa Cruz mountains in short we now
know where our async test facility is
hidden it's here the epicenter of that
devastating quink and from that point
forward the world appears to be glitched
we see in the video missing persons that
from October 1989 onward huge numbers of
ordinary people just start to go missing
as they know clip through reality
falling into this newly opened back
rooms meta space all the while async is
slowly exploring the this new
environment on February 3rd 1990 they
have their first major Discovery a
mysterious dead body coded in what
appears to be some type of black mold or
aged blood splatter so far in the series
he remains as an unidentified John Doe
but my suspicion is that this is
actually Nicholas Bolton a missing
person that we see at the top of the
upload notice a few of the details here
first he's not wearing a hazmat suit
which clearly tells us that this is not
an async employee instead it's someone
who no clipped into the back room second
compare their physical appearances
notice the wider nose Hall forehead the
hoodie just like we see on Nicholas's
missing poster around the same time we
also see that async's government
contract appears to have been canceled
in the next video autopsy report we get
Quick Cuts of various images on a screen
one image here is the top line of a
document with the words contract
termination things aren't looking too
great for async and they're about to get
worse just shy of one month later the
fourth member of an async exploration
crew is lured away from the Rest by
mysterious voices in the walls and
ceiling only to see his team glitch out
of space when he tries to rejoin them
guys can you hear this
hey guys can you hear this
hey
[Music]
guys
Jeff now lost he wanders the hallways
stumbling across a bizarre theater with
burned remains in the middle of the
floor as well as a smaller crawl space
with non-carpeted floors Forest print
wallpaper and the facade of a house with
farm equipment out front as he continues
his search we see what looks to be an
exit into an async control room
considering his keycard works on the
door and his sounds of relief but it
winds up empty and his presence triggers
a red alert end of upload about a week
later on March 5th async rigs cameras to
motion sensors to capture the action of
what's going on in the back rooms while
people aren't there we see async crew
members constructing more walls yeah
cause that's what the back rooms needed
more rooms Humanity you dumb later that
night at 3am the camera's capture a
bizarre dark shape that seems to be
moving along the walls or the ceiling
looks like the back room's monster has
been watching some YouTube videos don't
explore the back rooms at 3am asterisk
scary asterisky you will cry asterisk
shookus which then brings us all the way
back to the the first ever upload Kane's
original found footage video in 1996 a
young cinematographer named Kane no
clips through the ground falling into
the back rooms where he encounters some
kind of monster that attacks and
presumably kills him sending his camera
falling through yet another clip and
back out into reality if you go frame by
frame during this moment you can
actually see Kane's whole body here
being attacked by the monster as the
camera Falls it's a very cool little
detail that I noticed so anyway that's
the story that we've gotten thus far but
it leaves plenty of major questions for
us to speculate about what's the nature
of the back rooms what is the monster
roaming the Halls why are their voices
and farmhouses hidden inside the walls
well let's start with the monster is it
human doesn't appear to be you can
probably also eliminate animal and bird
an insect nah maybe some kind of robot
it looks a little bit like one if you
squint but then again I've always got
animatronics on the brain so I'm a
little bit biased I've seen some people
suggest that it could be a ghost or an
energy monster no energy Monster not
Monster Energy regardless we can
eliminate both options because it has a
physical form it is able to throw
objects and grab Kane now I think the
back rooms has already told us what this
thing is it's a mutated bacteria now I
know bacteria are supposed to be really
small literally microorganisms whereas
the back room's monster is anything but
however one thing that bacteria love to
do is form Colonial organisms animals
that are actually groups of smaller
animals all Voltron together tldr I
think that is what we're looking at here
a colonial organism composed of bacteria
possibly one that's been further mutated
by exposure to human DNA specifically a
mutated strain of hay bacillus that may
seem specific but there's a definite
reason for it you see after async
discovers the mysterious dead body they
conduct an autopsy report on it
confirming that it's been decayed at
uneven rates that haven't been overtaken
by a mutated strain of bacteria it's
like a portion to the body
stopped decaying and were sustained I
took a couple examples of some material
here it seems to be closer to a mutated
strain of simple hypocillis it should be
completely benign but really I I don't
know what to make of this well don't
worry doc because I do you see hey
bacillus also known as bacillus subtleus
is pretty darn common living in places
like the human and cow digestive systems
it's a rod-shaped bacteria that's
generally pretty harmless and science
loves these little guys it's used a lot
in experiments because it's very easy to
genetically modify this is one of the
all-purpose cultures you'll find in
almost any lab using bacteria for
research because it's durable it's
manipulable and it adapts in a very
elastic way and because it's so strong
and resilient it's been used to test out
extreme environments like outer space
which I call out because later in the
video autopsy report we see that quick
Montage of images I mentioned earlier
and it includes close-ups of bacteria
cultures along with rocket and space
imagery all seeming to relate to this
very idea oh yeah and it's also been
used by the military between 1950 and
1970 the U.S army released aerosolized
bacteria believed to be harmless over
populated areas of the country without
telling anyone all to study what the
impact might look like if an enemy ever
tried something similar another test was
conducted on the New York Subway system
in 1966 utilizing our little hay
bacteria they kind of just dumped it in
through the sewer grates and people
dusted it off their shoulders here's the
thing Army when you're on a New York
Subway the biggest biological threat
isn't the sketchy bacteria powder that
you're dumping on us it's the guy open
mouth hacking into my face during rush
hour anyway all this about durability
and space and genetic mutation makes me
think that our monster is a walking
roaring bacteria culture surviving in
the back rooms and evolving by coming
into contact with the humans that keep
no clipping in and that's not just
speculation either Kane has seemed to
confirm parts of this recently on his
Kofi account which is basically like his
patreon he dropped this picture of the
monster EX explicitly labeled as
bacteria something tells me you're gonna
need some more than antibiotics to kill
that bacterial infection now that is
what I call biological warfare so that's
a little bit about the monster but then
what are the back rooms themselves what
exactly are they and what's their nature
telling us about the world this story is
set in well when talking about internet
urban legends to base a video series
around the back rooms is still pretty
new the original meme dates to 2019 the
lore and branching args all come up
later and these videos have all gone up
in the last few months this is a brand
new evolving concept but the bigger idea
that it's grounded in that the world we
know has secret Hollow spaces behind the
scenes that we aren't supposed to enter
that idea goes way back into ancient
mythology and folklore probably as old
as the human psyche itself the ancient
Greeks believe that spirits of the dead
and plenty of other things inhabited an
entire underworld of caves and caverns
the 19th century French occultist Joseph
Alexander santives Marquis De elevonne
how's that for a name Advance what he
claimed was evidence of an inner world
inside the Earth itself called agartha
that some people still think is a thing
today even the idea of just ordinary
maintenance tunnels and access shafts
all over the world being connected to a
more Sinister purpose was part of the
background mythology in Jordan Peel's
horror movie us
it's a very familiar looking wallpaper
but of them all the back rooms is
probably most similar to the work of
mid-20th century sci-fi horror Creator
Richard Matheson he wrote the stories
that inspired I Am Legend and the
Incredible Shrinking man as well as many
many episodes of Star Trek and Twilight
Zone including the infamous Gremlin on
the Wing episode with William Shatner
[Music]
but perhaps most importantly for us
today he wrote little girl lost an
episode of The Twilight Zone that was so
iconic it would be parodied by The
Simpsons years later in one of their
Halloween episodes using really
expensive for the Time 3D animation it's
like
did anyone see the movie Tron no no no
no no no no no no
I mean no in both versions of the story
a character accidentally finds
themselves passing through an
imperceptible Rift between our Dimension
and another unable to find their way out
getting lost in a vast confusing
repetitive maze sound familiar really
similar to the idea of falling into the
back rooms in fact the only real
difference between all these stories is
the terminology involved for the
original back rooms lore they say that
you've no clipped through reality a
phrase borrowed from video games to
describe when solid graphical elements
pass through one another in a way that
the program doesn't intend resulting in
a player character ending up in an empty
space outside of the quote-unquote level
box this sometimes allows you to skip
around and cheat especially when you're
talking about older games when
developers were still figuring out how
to make 3D work now Kane pixels's back
rooms has yet to make any explicit
reference to this we have never heard
the phrase no clipping and we have not
once seen any references to video games
or digital worlds in fact Kane's Series
has taken the general concept to the
back rooms and layering on as science
fiction rationale to ground it in a very
believable reality and yet the video
game stuff I think this is exactly what
he's building towards and the key is
right here at 5 45 in the very first
upload check out the Rope it's sitting
there just sitting right there at first
I thought nothing of it it's just
garbage on the ground whatever but then
one month later we get this at the
midpoint of informational video as the
Lost async employee explores the smaller
crawl space with forced wallpaper he
stumbles across the facade of a
farmhouse and near it is this an ax
leaning against the wall again a
singular object just sitting there alone
waiting to get picked up so we're
wandering through a maze made of
geometric shapes and repeating textures
stalked by a monster and random useful
objects or just sitting there out in the
open on the ground waiting to get picked
up no real context around them it looks
a lot to me like a video game the kind
of video game you might no clip in or
out of to me this whole area with the
tree texture wallpaper the facade of a
house on the wall the random old time
farm tools that just look slightly
geometrically off this looks like the
exact way older 3D video games I'm
talking PlayStation 1 era would use
polygons and flat textures to try and
render outdoors and nature settings
within level box designs they would
paint the walls to look like trees they
would paper the sky blue with textures
they would stick a house facade onto a
giant rectangle to surround the door
that they want you to go into check out
the wheelbarrows specifically the
Shadows of the wheelbarrows notice how
they don't really move or shift position
as the bright flashlight beam moves well
this certainly could be just 3D
animation issues it also reflects how
many early video games couldn't or
didn't use Dynamic shaders Shadows if
they existed at all tended to be fixed
and painted onto textures this saved on
processing power but also gave objects a
bit of a flat look there's even a point
where our async employee leans in close
to the wheelbarrows where it looks like
the wallpaper pixel smears into just
color lines again like you'd see in a
video game with texture mapping on the
fritz so if the back rooms is indeed the
space you go to when you no clip through
the ground like like we see Kane do in
episode 1 then we're looking at evidence
that reality itself on our side of the
threshold is also a simulation it could
very well be that this whole series is
just a modern take on The Matrix a
simulation that no one realizes they're
in and when async opens the door to the
back rooms they're finding a storage
area for the extra unused assets that
procedurally generated world the levels
that just haven't quite made the cut yet
as Kane explores the various levels in
the series's first upload we see office
supplies and warehouses but also
residential style railings and exteriors
of buildings that are clearly indoors
hardwood floors repeating filing
cabinets it's a mishmash of random
assets like when you're exploring a
library of 3D assets from something like
a game engine all of reality being a
simulation would also explain the voices
that lore the async employee away in
informational video listen to the sound
these aren't voices that are explicitly
trying to lure him away it's not
Sinister in any way it's just general
white noise of a busy office or a party
all almost as though reality is breaking
through well he's wandering around in a
simulation on a computer an office party
is going on one layer of reality up but
outside of the wall textures and random
objects just sitting out in the open
like a video game there's one piece of
evidence that really clinches it for me
something that gets me to raise my
eyebrow notice the date on this upload
February 29 1990. here's the mind blow
that can't be correct there is no such
day in existence February has 28 days
and 1990 was not a leap year hey to me
this wasn't a mistake Kane already
picked first Contact to happen on a day
when a major real world earthquake
occurred the dates in this series matter
it tells me that we're existing in a
reality different from our own one where
a February 29 1990 can exist a simulated
reality and the back rooms is the
boundary between worlds where the
separation becomes just a little bit
thinner allowing things like office
voices and who knows maybe even in a
virulent bacteria into the simulation am
I right will async be able to break
through the boundary I guess we'll just
have to wait and see but hey that's just
a theory a film Theory and cut
[Music]